thanks so much for joining us here at 11
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis nearly 48 hours after a woman was
shot and killed at a house party
neighbors are opening up about the
problems they've seen at that very home
22 year old graciela gomez died late
saturday night on the east side of town
no arrests have been made yet madison
kimbrough speaking with neighbors
tonight she's live at metro headquarters
with more
a community tonight mourning the loss of
a friend now an outpour of post on
twitter asking anyone for information
for help and
asking that if you know anything to
please come forward
a house party gone wrong as 22 year old
graciela gomez was shot and killed
sunday in a drive-by shooting two others
were injured and taken to u-m-c
neighbors in this sunrise manor
neighborhood say parties like this go
down every weekend and it has to stop
there have been so many cars so we can't
even get into our own house lots and
lots of kids
clouds of marijuana speeding racing up
and down the highway here
fights drunkenness i mean it's just
crazy unfortunately it takes a level of
this kind of magnitude to actually get
the neighbors to come together and say
it's just time to stop according to
jones the owner doesn't live at the home
but rents it out for parties and is
fully aware of the disruption it causes
to the neighborhood she's been very
defensive she said you know
shootings happen all the time it's not a
big deal
i mean that's the attitude and it just
pissed people off
according to metro police a group of men
who initially weren't allowed in the
party drove by sometime later and fired
shots hitting three people and then sped
off i saw everyone running out after
that you know we see the little one of
the girls that got hurt
or shot they were trying to give her cpr
and you know they were saying maybe she
will not make it
now we reached out to several people who
knew gomez but have yet to hear back the
two people that were sent to the
hospital were with non-life-threatening
injuries reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now